buongiorno a tutte ea tutti e grazie di
essere qui oggi
quante volte ci è capitato che studiando
viaggiando e lavorando fuori regione ci
chiedessero se dalle nostre parti si
parla solo tedesco e se l'inverno dura
tutto l'anno
a me qualche volta è successo e questo
equivoco piuttosto frequente non deriva
solamente da una parziale conoscenza del
territorio della geografia poi causato
in parte anche da un utilizzo un po
limitato di un concetto molto
interessante e altrettanto delicato che
è l'identità che cos'è l'identità
secondo le scienze sociali l'identità è
un concetto polisemico cioè portatore di
molti significati è sicuramente un
termine complesso è declinabile in tanti
modi e oggi vorrei vedere alcuni con voi
quello che possiamo dire innanzitutto
sull'identità e che l'identità riguarda
il modo in cui l'individuo chiunque esso
sia costruisce definisce se stesso come
appartenente a un determinato gruppo
sociale che può essere una nazione una
classe sociale un'etnia il genere la
professione qualsiasi tipo di identità
che ci può venire in mente
l'identità quindi serve per riconoscersi
come appartenenti ad un gruppo e allo
stesso tempo per farsi riconoscere dagli
altri come membri di un gruppo
è una necessità mentale che noi abbiamo
di differenziarci dagli altri e funziona
più o meno come una scorciatoia mentale
che ci aiuta a far capire velocemente
chi siamo senza doversi per forza
conoscere direttamente ogni volta
secondo l'antropologia l'identità è
costruita principalmente su tre elementi
e costruita sull'alterità perché la
questione del chi sono io sorge
inevitabilmente nel momento in cui una
persona si trova davanti a un altro a
qualcuno con il quale differenziarsi
io sono qualcuno in virtù del fatto che
non sono qualcun altro posso dire di
avere i capelli scuri perché non gli ho
chiari
identità poi richiede una qualche forma
di stabilità e chiaro che se trattiamo
l'identità con una scorciatoia che si
aiuta a capire chi siamo questa identità
dovrà essere valida e fissa nel tempo
almeno per un certo periodo non possiamo
infatti permetterci di avere un punto di
riferimento che cambia che volvo è
troppo veloce nel tempo
ultimo elemento l'identità richiede una
qualche forma di definizione è costruita
su un processo di definizione può essere
auto diretta quando io mi auto riconosco
come appartenente ad un gruppo oppure
può essere etero diretta quando viene
definita da fuori da qualcuno che ha il
potere di definire gli altri all'interno
di una chiara relazione di potere
l'identità quindi svolge una funzione
fondamentale nel costruire definire le
relazioni tra le persone e tra i gruppi
e lo fa nel bene e nel male basta
pensare infatti a qualsiasi fatto
storico presente o passato in cui
l'identità è stata utilizzata per
motivare e giustificare le proprie
azioni
questo processo identitario interessa
anche la montagna
la montagna infatti ha un'identità che
risulta essere spesso idealizzata
l'immagine mentale che si forma nella
nostra testa quando pensiamo parliamo
della montagna ci presenta infatti un
posto incontaminato pulita autentico
genuino sincero così come le persone che
abitano in questo posto sono spesso
viste come residui lavoratrici vere
oneste e anche un po schivo e qualche
volta da dove viene questa costruzione
mentale
a ben vedere costruita sulla doppia
alterità è un'attività temporale perché
la montagna è vista come immobile nel
tempo uno spazio dove le cose non
succedono non accadono non si modificano
uno spazio legato alle tradizioni in cui
la modernità non è ancora arrivata e
dall'altra parte costruita sull'alterità
spaziale perché la montagna è lontana è
lontana geograficamente
sicuramente ma questa lontananza alle
volte ha significato marginalità ed è
una marginalità che viene intesa oggi
come una mancanza di partecipazione alle
scelte
e spesso conosce
ciao
sto andando
ok allora dicevamo che la l'identità
della montagna è costruita su una doppia
alterità spaziale temporale
ma questa alterità da dove viene in un
discorso dicotomico quando si parla di
alterità ci devono essere due poli in
questo caso si parla di alterità nei
confronti di un ambiente urbano in cui
la città è vista come il centro come il
posto dove le cose succedano si evolvono
si modificano dove c'è la vita in
contrapposizione alle valli montane che
sono periferiche lontane e dove sembra
che non succede niente i cambiamenti
arrivano molto molto tempo dopo e la
cosa importante è che questa
rappresentazione mentale spesso viene
vista come
naturale come una realtà esistita da
sempre ma è proprio vero che la montagna
immobile e marginale
se guardiamo bene la storia ci rendiamo
conto che non è così nei secoli nei
millenni la montagna è cambiata tanto è
cambiata tanto è assunto delle funzioni
molto diverse si è come è successo anche
nella in città l'antropologa annibale
salsa in uno studio molto interessante
sulle identità tradizionali delle alpi
ci racconta che sono esistiti diversi
tipi di montagna nel neolitico per
esempio la montagna veniva vissuta in
insediamenti sparsi ed era uno spazio di
attraversamento di spostamento i passi i
valichi venivano regolarmente utilizzati
per scambiare le merci per spostarsi
secondo le ultime ricerche si muoveva
tra l'austria in italia proprio per
questo scopo
durante l'impero romano la prospettiva
cambia i romani sono organizzati sono
abituati a vivere nei centri urbani e
questo è il modello che loro esportano
da buoni colonizzatori quali sono e
quindi ci si sposta le mezze quote e la
montagna diventa un luogo pauroso
inviolabile utilizzato solo per un
attraversamento molto veloce e nel
medioevo intorno all'anno mille che
inizia a prendere forma la montagna è
così come noi oggi la vediamo molto
simile dei gruppi di contadini si
spostano nelle terre alte per insediarsi
nelle zone che vengono via via liberate
dal bosco e quindi di sodano la terra la
curano la abitano e lo fanno in cambio
della libertà in montagna si formano
quindi dei sistemi di autogoverno che
sono molto lontani dalla situazione del
fondovalle dove vivono ancora i diritti
servili
nell epoca napoleonica poi la montagna
assume un'altra funzione e diventa uno
spazio di guerra lo resterà per tanto
tempo sta pensare ai conflitti mondiali
perché perché in quel periodo si andava
affermando il modello dello stato
nazione e lo stato nazione ha bisogno di
confini per esistere e ogni confine tra
presero nei confi e rappresenta una
nazionalità è una lingua e quindi i
confini diventano delle zone da
presidiare da difendere da controllare
delle zone per cui vale la pena
combattere e anche morire nel novecento
infine la terra la montagna perdere sue
funzioni diventa una terra povera
diventa una terra povera che spesso è
stata trascurata e abbandonata
e si rapporta sempre di più il modello
della città come centro e la montagna
come luogo marginale si ritornerà alla
montagna negli anni cinquanta e sessanta
del novecento quando prende piede il
mondo il modello odierno di turismo e
questa volta una montagna idealizzata è
una montagna come abbiamo detto prima
che è incontaminata e pulita e un posto
bello al cuore fa il ritorno scappando
dalla città che nel frattempo è
diventata luogo caotico rumoroso
invivibile
ecco che questo piccolo viaggio nel
tempo ci fa capire che la montagna non è
mai stata immobile
la montagna non ha mai avuto una sola
identità è stata lo spazio di
spostamenti di risorse naturali di
guerre di scambi di abbandono di
divertimento e cosa più importante che
la montagna sempre vissuto in relazione
con il fondovalle qualche volta in
opposizione e qualche volta in dialogo
ecco quindi che la montagna ha
un'identità ma forse in virtù di quel
che abbiamo detto fino adesso questa
identità può essere rivista e
reinterpretata attraverso un nuovo
concetto questo concetto è stato
elaborato qualche anno fa da due
studiosi del territorio ivo povinelli e
ugo morelli che non ci parlo più di
identità ma di una di vendita come
un'identità che diventa un'identità che
cambia che muove che si evolve in
relazione ai cambiamenti sociali
economici politici culturali che
interessano la società la società della
montagna e la società del fondovalle
la di vendita quindi ci permette di
reinterpretare la cultura e la società
se prima l'identità era fissa e stabile
adesso diventa flessibile mutevole se
prima l'identità tendeva a rafforzare la
diversità costruendo delle barriere
adesso è un confine poroso che è
possibile attraversare in vari vari modi
se prima l'identità era un fatto di
attribuzione di nascita
adesso diventa uno spazio di
negoziazione tra le persone e tra le
persone e l'ambiente nel quale remo non
è una questione di scelta
montanari non si nasce
montanari si diventa nel momento in cui
si sceglie di interagire con la montagna
adattando il proprio vissuto sociale
economico politico alle richieste
particolari di questo ambiente che è
solo apparentemente statico di quanto
anch'esso partecipa in realtà al vissuto
le vicende del mondo
quello che gli abitanti della montagna
fanno oggi e cercare
l'autodeterminazione
cioè la possibilità di scegliere come
gestire il proprio territorio e
continuare a vivere nelle proprie valli
e devono poterlo fare al di fuori di
ogni stereotipo che vede la montagna con
eccessivo pessimismo con una zona
marginale arretrata sottosviluppata o
con troppo ottimismo come un luogo
incontaminato la culla della tradizione
e lo fanno sempre lo fanno da sempre
probabilmente lo fanno rielaborando le
vecchie tradizioni e rileggendo le in
chiave moderna come è stato fatto con un
progetto molto bello sulla lana
organizzato proprio dal dal parco
paneveggio pale di san martino che ci
ospita lo fanno ridefinendo gli spazi e
le dimensioni locali
collegando zone di montagna con nuove
tecnologie o con vecchi sistemi di
trasporto riportati in funzione lo fanno
rielaborando nuove forme di coesione
sociale proponendo per esempio rinnovate
professionalità come è stato fatto dalla
scuola d'inverno l'ultimo un bellissimo
esempio di come si possa costruire
insieme delle strategie dei sistemi per
migliorare la vivibilità delle terre
alte e lo fanno innovando con tecnologia
ad alta sostenibilità sono davvero tanti
gli esempi di questi di questo
cambiamento dinamico che interessa tutto
l'arco alpino
dimentichiamo quindi dimentichiamo
sempre lo facciamo perché siamo esseri
umani perché siamo vivi
biologicamente cambiamo ogni giorno ci
sono cellule che nascono cellule che si
ammalano cellule che guariscono e che
invecchiano e solo quando moriamo che
smettiamo davvero di cambiare e quindi
noi ci trasformiamo ci trasformiamo per
natura ma anche per cultura
questo non significa purtroppo anche
siamo disposti ad accettare che tutti
possono dimenticare esattamente come noi
e in che cosa forse potremo migliorare
da questo punto di vista
secondo me è semplicemente guardandoci
intorno con più consapevolezza più
attenzione più interesse verso il
diverso perché l'altro in fin dei conti
ci aiuta a capire meglio chi siamo e
cosa vogliamo per il nostro futuro in
montagna così come nelle nostre terre
alte grazie
no